this plastic creature appears to be
breathing and with each heave suggests a
vision of what the world's consumption
of plastics could bring to life South
Korean artist iang Chan explains that
Plastics became Central to his work when
he realized how widespread they
were when I was in school I often bought
a gimbab and cup noodles at convenience
stores they'd be handed to me in a
plastic bag time and time again so much
that they became an integral part of my
life in the city Le's creature is
refashioned to amplify campaigners call
for
change we're demanding that plastic
production be slashed by at least 75% by
20140 based on various research that is
what's required to avert a climate
crisis according to the UN 2/3 of the
430 million tons of plastic produced
each year are thrown away after only one
or just a few uses overflowing landfill
sites microplastics have been found in
Sea Life sheet ice and human blood as
negotiators debate a treaty with a
deadline next year Lee says the sea
change that's needed can start
today I never regarded myself as an
environmentalist but when I was starting
out I was buying less clothes less
things and organically came to think
more about the environment if people
just take a moment to consider the
environmental impact of their actions I
think that would make a difference with
less than 9% of single-use plastics
being recycled the UN says the world
stands to see a tripling of plastic
pollution within decades that's why many
are calling for a legally binding
International pact that not only
regulates the way Plastics are reused
but also produced and designed Unis Kim
Al jazer
soul make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz